one of my everyday essentials is my
security guard Kevin come say hi to the
people does they look happy hi GQ I'm Ed
Sheran and these are my
[Music]
essentials Kevin has spent pretty much
every day of my life with me since 2015
he was there on the birth of both of my
children he was on my honeymoon yeah
we're we're best friends
and you know it's a deterrent people see
him and they go okay maybe I won't robed
what's the craziest story that comes to
mind out of the last 8 years none I can
say you it's the strong silent type I've
never seen Kevin in an altercation and I
think that's what makes Kev a good
security guard he gets me out of the
danger before it's even presented itself
he's not the only one as well he's got
he's got a few few
mates hey few of us
yeah so this is another essential this
is tingly Ted's hot sauce I did a TV
commercial for Hines ketchup cuz I like
Hines and I got in contact with them and
said I've got a commercial idea for you
if you want to do it together and then
they asked should we do another
commercial for Hines ketchup and I said
I'd actually want to create my own sauce
I had this idea for tingly Ted a while
ago I find some hot sauce a bit too
runny and watery not fit for purpose so
I wanted to create something that was
totally fit for the purpose that I I use
hot sauce on like every everything I'm a
spice addict but I wanted something with
the taste that I like and a consistency
and something you can cook with as well
so this I mean I go through bottles and
bottles and bottles of this every single
week I'd have it on breakfast lunch
Burgers nuggets I'd cook fajitas with it
cook pasta cook curries there's two
flavors out of the moment but we're
bringing out a uh I like to call it the
hoop hurter and that will be coming out
very soon and anyone that really really
likes their Rings stinged then you
know next essential is uh Apple TV
I travel a lot and I find myself sat in
a hotel room on my own a lot and this
has all the streaming platforms on and I
can basically wherever I am in the world
if I've got like you know an hour to
kill I can go on choose a TV show choose
a movie and and watch that I mean this
this comes with me everywhere I put it
in my dressing room I put it in my hotel
room I have it at home it's yeah a very
useful bit of Kit being on Game of
Thrones was it was cool it was it was
very cold and they gave me thermal
everything thing and I was like ah it's
Northern irand it's not going to be that
cold and it was like I really regretted
the decision not wearing thermals the
reaction to me being on Game of Thrones
was obviously not as glowing uh and
positive as how I felt about it but what
I would say to people is if someone
asked you to be on your favorite show
you'd say yes
too so one of my essentials on the road
is having a watch like this which is a
uh it's just a regular G-Shock this is I
did a subtract Edition I love collecting
watches but I think having a watch that
you can wear anywhere and everywhere and
you can swim with this you can run with
this you could you could go to a club
with this you can go but I wouldn't have
to have a security guard and I always
have this in my bag to wear at all times
I love it so this watch uh was made for
me for the mathematics tour and it's a a
oneof one all the mathematics colors and
symbols on it's basically a stage watch
for me every weekend for the uh for the
stadium shows but I basically bring both
of these on the road this would be the
everyday wear and this would be the
stage
watch
another one of my essentials would be V5
hair wax this is texturizing gum I've
used this not this particular one
although this is about 11 years old this
it's it's empty um yeah I've used this
probably since I was about 13 uh I name
dropped V5 in my song you need me I
don't need you and they sent me a
lifetime supply that say Edge Shar and's
texturizing gum and when they said
lifetime supply I've still got a lot of
the supply and you know I'm barely
halfway through it so it is definitely a
lifetime supply yeah I've only ever used
this on my hair and yeah I've run out
which is why I'm wearing a hat today but
yeah I know gel not for me matte clay
not for me hairspray not for me it's all
about the texturizing gum but then I
don't know if anyone's going to watch
this video and go oh I'd love to have
hair that looks like EDS but if you
[Laughter]
do so this is another one of my
essentials this is Paca raban million
just a a spray this the same as the the
texturizing G I've used this since I was
about 16 the only reason I got it was
cuz it looked
fancy and I was 16 and you know I think
the one I got was like this big as well
it was like I got it with a voucher for
Christmas but I've used it ever since
and I guess like when you find your
smell it's your smell I really think
like I I meet a lot of people throughout
the day and you know I think people look
at me and they think he looks like he
doesn't smell nice
and I try to so this is is I think the
thing that I use the most in the day
this is my iPad Mini yeah I moved off a
phone in 2015 and I didn't have any form
of communication for about a year I was
just like off everything and then when I
got back to work for divid I was like
I'm going to move back on to email
everyone expects a reply to a text
instantly with email for some reason
culturally everyone's like yeah yeah
yeah you can reply to that tomorrow and
it's not like you're just spending your
whole time on your phone and I have
three folders I have personal work and
Urgent for me to compartmentalize
conversations rather than just having
chaos it's helpful for brain space
especially with a young family I
actually write every single one of my
songs on here as well so on notes all of
my lyrics are written on here on uh
voice notes as well all of my ideas for
like guitar riffs and stuff like that so
this is a an important bit of Kit and
it's really smashed up like really
really smashed up I made a load of songs
with Jay Balvin and he was so offended
that my iPad was so smashed up and I was
using like it was literally like holes
in it that he like bought me a new one
then and there and yeah that's this one
and it's smashed up so Jose thank you
but it's it's the same as the one you
replaced these uh headphones I have like
seven pairs of these cuz I keep losing
them and then and then finding them
again so these are don't know these
aren't the pros yeah I think headphones
are essential for anything I mean for me
checking mixes of my music I video call
my kids and stuff like that so to be
able to be in private basically in
public I think is quite important the
three artists I would listen to for the
rest of my life I think the Beatles I'm
going to choose artists that have a wide
wide wide catalog cuz there are some
artists that are my favorite artists but
have like two or three albums and if it
was for rest of my life I'd want to have
a wide catalog I would say the Beatles I
would say Eminem and for
[Music]
events so another one of my essentials
would be a corkscrew bottle opener for
uh wine I stopped drinking Spirits a
couple of years ago and I've kind of uh
channeled all my energy into into red
wine yeah I've been caught out a few
times where you're in a situation where
you have a bottle of wine and you want
to drink it and I've learned how to push
a cork down now and basically open a
bottle without a cork screw but
sometimes especially wearing a white
t-shirt it's dangerous you push it in
and goes all over you so I would say a
cork screw is essential in my bag I
would say a bottle of wine as well but I
think that it that's not essential to
bring with you at all times cuz you
could pretty much anywhere in the world
you can find a bottle of
wine this is the only thing that I carry
on my person apart from a watch I have a
wallet I used to carry a wallet with
cash in it and yeah cash just seems to
be a thing of the past now so I just
literally have a credit card I feel like
I could be caught out in any situation
and be fine with even if I didn't have a
watch just a credit card I think you
could get yourself out of a few binds
Just One credit card yeah and I've got a
card that someone gave me for counseling
custody and
meditation that it sometimes has cards
in there you know that people give me
and I forget to take out but yeah I
should probably take that one out I've
watched so many of these and it's nice
to be the one being watched today i'
I've always wondered about what my
essentials would be and I really wanted
to pick things that were actually in my
bag and yeah thank you so much for
having me and hope you enjoy the next
person whoever it
is